The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good afternoon.
Today we're going to go
beyond the way we've
spoken about before.
We've talked about how
psychologists measure the
mind, how neuroscientists
interrogate the brain.
And so now, we'll talk about the
first human faculty that
we'll consider in a series
of faculties
through the course, Vision--
How We See.
And for today's lecture, I got
help from Melissa Troyer, one
of your teaching assistants.
So, one of the things we can
think about is what are the
purposes of vision?
What do we use sight for?
And we'll talk about that.
Problems that the visual
system has to overcome.
What are the obstacles for
vision to work accurately and
efficiently?
And how does the brain
organization of vision serve
the human capacity to see?
So human perceptual abilities
are amazing, as are perceptual
abilities of many species
in different areas.
But humans can detect a candle
30 miles away on
a dark, clear night.
They can detect cochlear
displacements
that's in your ear--
equal to the width of
a hydrogen atom.
You can taste 1 teaspoon of
sugar, even when it's mixed in
two gallons of water.
You can smell a drop of perfume
diffused into the
space of a three-bedroom
apartment.
So the human capacity to
perceive the world in a highly
sensitive way is remarkable.
We're going to focus on vision
specifically today.
And think, what do we
use vision for?
Well, how does it serve us in
dealing with the world?
And researchers have thought
about two major reasons that
we see, two purposes
of vision.
One of them is object
recognition.
Recognizing things
in the world.
People we know, words
we can read,
chairs, tables, animals--
all kinds of things that
we see out there.
And we need to know who they are
or what they are in order
to operate in the world.
And the second one is a little
bit different, navigation--
getting around in the world.
When you're running, when you're
jumping, when you're
reaching to grab something,
you're not usually much
interested in what something
is, as where you're moving,
where you need to move
to avoid something
being thrown at you.
So two big purposes
of vision--
what things are and where they
are, so you can navigate
around quickly in the world.
And when we think about purposes
of vision, for what
things are or where they are,
psychologists and people
working in computer vision have
recognized a series of
problems that our visual
system has to solve.
We have to link unique images.
Because when we see something,
it'll almost always look
different from one perceptual
moment to the next.
We can see the same person,
for example, but under
different conditions of
illumination, darkness or
lightness or shadows, the angle
we see them at, the
distance we see them at, the
expression on their face-- a
smile or frown--
shadows that might be being
cast, occlusion, a thing
blocking part of their face.
And yet, we can recognize a
person very well under all
these circumstances.
So what arrives in our
eye is different from
all of these views.
But what we interpret them
is all the same.
That's a person I know.
The same thing with letters.
We can see letters in all kinds
of fonts and all kinds
of handwriting, and yet we can
interpret what they are in a
uniform way.
Or body.
We can see bodies of all kinds
of different positions.
But our visual system
lets us know right
away that it's a person.
And so psychologists have tried
to formalize these kinds
of problems to ones
of equivalents.
So something is the same thing
at different views.
Generalization--
something has a very
different shape.
Or impoverished input, where
there's poor lighting or
something's complicated.
And you still figure
out what it is.
For getting around in the world
or where things are in
the world, you're moving
through space
and tracking things.
And there's many sources
of movement.
Your eyes are constantly
moving.
Your head is moving.
Your body is moving.
And the world is moving.
And you have to sort
all those out.
Run quickly.
Jump [INAUDIBLE]
world spatially.
And so here's some examples.
Here's a shape constancy
problem.
Here's two different
versions of a cat.
It's trivial for you to know
that even though these things
have different shapes, they
represent the same thing.
But that's an achievement of
your visual system, to easily
make that equivalence across
two very different shapes.
And we know, from computer
vision, how hard these
problems are.
No computer vision system sees
with anything like the
generalized ability of
a very young child.
So our visual systems are so
brilliant that psychologists
and vision scientists really
interrogate our visual system
to figure out, how
do we do it.
If people didn't do this, we'd
think it would be impossible
to accomplish at all.
Here's another example that's
easily solved by people-- not
so easily solved by machines.
If you see something like a car
at different angles, we
know that's the same thing,
pretty easily, even though,
again, the information that
arrives to our eyes is
radically different.
And the same thing can be said
of something like all these
different versions
of the letter C.
Radically different shapes.
But we can readily interpret
almost all them-- this one
won't be too tough--
as the letter C.
So our visual system does
this brilliantly.
And also you get very
impoverished views.
A key might be covered by
something, clothes on a hook.
There might be a
book over here.
There might be a fire hydrant
over here or a person.
And yet, even though you get
only partial information, it's
relatively trivial to discover,
for you, what it is
you're looking at.
Or you can see things like
you've never seen before.
The pink elephant, this odd
picture, this striped ...
you've never seen them before
but it's not really ...
So again, your visual system
is just so brilliant at
matching what it sees with what
you know to figure out
what's in front of you.
So today we're going to talk
about how our minds and brains
allow us to see the
world vision.
And we'll talk about it in three
parts; how philosophers
and psychologists have thought
about the idea of seeing; how
when information first enters
your eye-- your retina--
which are set of layers in the
back of the eye; how that
retina's already organized to
help you see the world; and
how that information is then
transported into the cortex,
where higher-level processing
lets you know where you are
and what you're looking at.
So the ideas about how we learn
to see the world have
their roots in philosophy.
For example, John Locke is
associated with the idea of
the blank slate or
tabula rosa.
He said, "Let us suppose the
mind to be a white paper void
of any characters, without
any ideas.
How comes it to be furnished?
Whence comes it by that vast
store, which the busy and
boundless fancy of man has
painted on it with an almost
endless variety?" Where do we
get the information for how
the world works when
we look at it?
And his answer to that
was experience.
That we notice things around us,
and experience drives our
understanding of the world.
And that position that there's
a blank slate and we learn
objectively from the world
around us has been called the
Objectivist view.
And maybe, that we see the world
that we build up through
experience, knowledge about how
to accurately represent
what's around us.
The alternative you has
emphasized how much our mind
organizes what we see, instead
of what's out there itself.
And so Gestalt psychologists or
Gestalt views on perception
say, it's not what's out there
in the world, but the way our
mind organizes and believes
what's out there.
And these two things
can come together.
So for example, when you think
about how you listen to a
piano, music comes from
piano the same way a
pianist strikes chords.
There's things out there in
the world that you see.
The piano has certain
limitations.
It can sound like somethings
but not others.
It can't be a clarinet.
There's constraints in the world
on what's possible to
see what's out there.
And our percepts are evoked
by nature in this way.
But they are personal and
not a copy of nature.
In the words, we each,
individually, figure out
what's going on there by
our own experiences and
interpretation.
And they're exactly that-- an
interpretation, not a simple
mirroring or copy of nature.
So I'm going to try and convince
you of something that
might not be obvious to people
when they first think about
it, that vision is an
interpretation of the
world around us.
It's not simply a video camera
or mirror, it's an active
calculation of what's
out there.
And we see, through inference,
what we believe that we see.
And that visual illusions--
and you've seen some before, and
I'll show you some again--
are not just illusions to trick
people and confuse them.
But they're demonstrations of a
gap between what's actually
out there in the world and
how we interpret it.
Most of the time we don't
have illusions.
We don't walk into walls.
We don't misidentify people
we know commonly.
Because illusions are rare,
because our minds and brains
have evolved to interpret the
world that's out there, and
the system works so brilliantly
coupled with the
environment that we actually
live in, that we
don't think about it.
So the person on the street
says, well, what
do I need to see?
I open my eyes.
But that's because our visual
system works so brilliantly,
effortlessly, and
automatically.
It's such a calculating machine
that that's why it
feels so simple.
So here's one, small example.
And I'll show you a number of
visual illusions that show us
how we're constantly
interpreting even the most
simple thing.
So for example, here's
two people.
And we're not worried that this
is one of the shortest
men you've ever seen, because we
know, through prospective,
this person's standing
back there.
Even though, if they were
standing right next to
somebody, you'd worry about
the size of that person.
So we're constantly interpreting
information by
the context in which
we see it.
Here's another example of the
choice of interpretations.
You can see a vase.
Or you can see two faces here. ,
Usually it's hard for people
to see them both
simultaneously.
They tend to flip
back and forth.
But you can choose the
interpretation of what you see.
So let me pick one example where
people have studied a
lot, which is the issue of
brightness constancy.
So here's the problem for
the visual system.
The ambient brightness, the
brightness around us, varies
in staggering ratios.
When we're outdoors in the
sun-- and even that's not
constant, right?
Sometimes it's a bright day.
Sometimes it's a cloudy day.
Sometimes we're indoors under
bright conditions or less
bright conditions.
So huge changes in the
ambient illumination.
Or in shadows-- we'll make
it even more complicated.
That means in a purely
measurement sense, in a purely
physics sense, a piece of coal
in sunlight reflects 10 times
as much light as snow
in the shade.
So think about that
for a moment.
You're not disturbed if
you see a piece of
coal inside or outside.
They both look, to you, like
black, dark pieces of coal.
And snow looks, pretty much, the
same to you if it's inside
or outside.
But if you're visual system
worked like a simple,
objective light meter, you would
conclude that the piece
of coal in the sunlight is a
much brighter thing-- in an
objective sense--
than snow in the shade.
And yet, you never make that
conclusion, because you're
constantly, automatically,
without effort, adjusting
mentally for the ambient
light condition.
So we use brightness all the
time to help us figure out is
that a piece of coal
or sunlight?
But that brightness perception
is constantly adjusted to
interpret brightness in the
context we're sitting in.
And perceptual psychologists
have worked on how people
calculate this.
So here's an example of a dark
letter T. Again, the black T
would be 10 times brighter
outdoors than
white paper is indoors.
And yet, you're never
bothered by that.
You can read a newspaper or
something else indoors or
outdoors with equal these,
because people are calculating
the ratio of the ambient
lighting--
lower inside, much brighter
outside, from the sun--
and using that information to
make inferences about the
relative brightness of a
stimulus they're looking at.
And there's all kinds of
examples or illusions that
show us this.
So for example, here, you detect
a white tile in the
shade and a gray tile
in brightness.
And that's how you
interpret it.
But that's because you're taking
already into account--
without even thinking about
it for a moment--
the fact that this is in the
shadow, and this is in the
bright light.
You're right in your
interpretation.
But if we show a constant
background, you could see that
those two are actually identical
in brightness.
The same thing-- you could take
a look at this cube and
this cube as part of these
Rubik's cubes.
This looks orange.
This looks brown.
You're adjusting for light,
as you make those
interpretations.
And if you make the background
constant, you can see those
are identical in color
and luminance.
So this shows you that we're
constantly making these
interpretations.
Only these tricks of visual
illusion make us realize that
our inferences are occasionally
wrong.
But they're incredibly right
almost all the time.
So here's another example
of taking a local
luminance into account.
So typically, people see
this as a lighter gray.
And this is a darker gray.
Again, they're using the
contrast that surrounds it to
make that interpretation.
Because if we give it a constant
background, you can
see that in an objective sense
the two are identical.
People use edges as a very
powerful source of information
to make these inferences.
And you can see that
in one moment.
Because this boundary, here,
is used to make judgments
about the relative brightness
around an object.
So you just do this.
The boundary disappears, and
the two things look equally
gray, one above the other.
Or no less spectacular, but
measured example, here's two
different shades of gray.
And if you're in a light meter,
objectively looking at
how much light is reflected from
this, here that changes.
This looks almost the
same as this.
But really, there's just
a manipulation at the
boundaries.
Again, here's a light meter.
Here's a boundary.
So these two sides are
really identical.
It's just been manipulated
by the boundary.
And you can see that, because
if you get rid of that
boundary, now you can
see that these two
sides are equally bright.
Another example, again, of how
we're constantly using local
information about brightness
to make
judgments about objects.
Here, you see a picture
of a woman.
Here's her forehead.
Here's her darker hair.
But in fact, that's a judgment
in interpretation.
Because if we cover up the
surrounding information, the
hair is identical to the face.
Here's some other illusions,
not all about brightness.
But, again, they're just
reminders that what we see is
constantly a calculation and an
interpretation of many factors.
So here's a fun spiral.
You can see it zooming around,
going from inner tightness and
unwinding peripherally.
And so we can add
a dot to that.
And now, we can let this travel
around to the middle.
You can see it's not quite
making the middle.
And we can try that again.
Because in fact, in this
picture, every line, every
circle is a circle.
And none of them are connected,
one to the other.
They just appear that way.
This illusion, that Richard
Gregory describes, was
inspired because he saw a wall
in a cafe that looked like it
had not been well assembled
by the person building it.
As if they had been consuming
something from the cafe as
they built the wall.
And bizarrely, having all kinds
of lines that are not
lined up, as you'd expect in
well-constructed tiles on a wall.
But in fact, every line, here,
is perfectly straight.
And you're interpreting the
black and white edges to
confuse you about the lining
up across the horizontal.
This is very striking.
Here's Rubik's cubes that,
again, now they're adding one
more story into this,
which is color.
But we use that often in every
day sight, of course, to make
conclusions about things.
And here, you can see the
difference between, for
example, this yellow cube
and this brown cube.
What did I want to do?
You can see the difference
between this brown cube--
sorry, let me get my
illusion correct--
and this darker cube, lighter
brown and darker brown.
But if we cover those up,
those are identical.
And they're gray.
Here's another one that shows
you it's not just the color
itself but the spatial
location.
So here's a pink circle, near
the middle of this display.
And here's a more orange one.
So we're just simply going to
expand those out and get it
bigger and bigger.
And as it's moving
across your eye--
even though, objectively, it
remains pink and orange, or
the things will lead you
to you interpret that--
as it gets big enough, the color
difference disappears to
your perception.
And sometimes you can
get-- and this is a
very complicated one--
illusions--
I don't know if it's
working for you--
that these things are actually
turning, even though none of
them are moving at all.
OK.
And one last, simple example.
Here's yellow on gray.
Here's light gray on yellow.
But in fact, these X's
are identical.
And you can see that when
they meet here.
So again, we're constantly
interpreting color, shape,
brightness, by things that
are surrounding it.
And everything is being the
product of an interpretation,
not what's out there in an
objective sense of self.
And so, if we think about this
Objectivist view that that
can't be right, that the limit
of this objective view would
be that everybody sees
everything differently all the
time, that would be a
confusing world of
hallucinations.
We don't live there
either, mostly.
So we think it's the because
there's a relationship between
these, or a synthesis.
We perceive only within limits
of our nervous system.
There's a way that
we see the world.
But the way that our nervous
system computes and makes
inferences about the world
reflects many properties of
the world that are efficient
and accurate.
So how do we get information
into our brains to see?
So, if you were to design a
system that was hopelessly
failed, the first thing you
would do is think the visual
system is going to fail.
The first thing it does is it
takes objects in the world and
it flips them upside down-- and
how they're perceived in
the eye, the front of the eye,
the back of the eye.
Here's the retina.
And the first place in your
brain that sees something is
in the back of your eye.
You'd think you would put it
in the front of your eye.
And information bounces
back into the
deepest part of the eye.
And then it comes out and leads
through the optic nerve.
You also know, from prior
classes, that the world is
organized by left and right
visual fields, instead of the
way we intuitively think
about the world.
Let's take a closer look
at the retina.
These layers of cells in your
eye that begin vision.
So light comes in and bounces
through the back.
And here are the rods and cones
where vision begins.
The cones are primarily
near the fovea.
The rods are primarily
peripheral.
And I'm reminding you, again, as
the optic nerve leaves, it
goes through the optic chiasm.
The fibers get sorted out by
whether they're having
information from the left or
right side of the world, and
then enter the cortex
that way.
Within the retina, within your
eye, here is a graphic of the
different kinds of cells.
Here's what the cells
actually look like.
And here's a blow up of these
remarkable cones, these larger
entities and the rods that you
can see are very small, but
many of them.
And the big difference between
rods and cones is that the
rods are receptive to
information at only one
wavelength.
They're effectively
color blind.
We'll come back to that.
But that's a good wavelength
to pick up information, for
example, in low light.
The cones are selective for
blue or red or green.
That's the stuff of
seeing color.
But it doesn't operate too well,
unless you have a pretty
well illuminated situation.
And the rods and cones have
a striking physical
organization.
So here's the distribution
of cones for color.
Pretty much, all of them in the
fovea in the middle part
of the retina.
And then the rods are spread
out peripherally.
So there's this big difference
in where they're located.
And another big difference is
that the cones, the ones that
respond to color, and that are
in the middle of the fovea,
have an almost one-to-one
relationship between the
receptors for color information
and the neurons
that leave the eye with
information that
will go into the brain.
The rods have a many-to-one
relationship.
Many rods are contributing for a
combined calculation of some
kind to a single neuron
that leaves the brain.
So you can already see, at the
very first moment of reception
from the rods and from the cons,
very different kinds of
processes are being begun,
as you begin to see.
Two ideas have been very helpful
for understanding how
vision is organized
in the brain--
our receptive fields
and retinotopy.
Receptive fields are, simply,
an area of external space.
It's a physical spot
in space in which a
stimulus activates a neuron.
So neurons, early in vision,
will respond to specific
locations in space when you're
looking straightforward.
One neuron might cover
this area.
Another neuron might cover
that area and so forth.
Retinotopy refers to topographic
or spatial maps of
visual space across
a restricted
region of the brain.
And so, retinotopy keeps these
receptive fields lined up.
So if the neuron is seeing this
spot, this retinotopic
map, and so the next spot
stays next to it.
And the next spot stays
next to it.
So you can reconstruct what
you see, based on a lot of
very local glances at
the environment.
And then it travels from the
eye, through the optic nerve,
into something called the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
The nucleus is simply a
collection of cells.
This is part of the thalamus.
And from there, the fibers will
travel into the cortex to
begin conscious visual
perception.
And you have one on the left
and one in the right of the
lateral geniculate nucleon.
And if you look at
this blown up--
this is a sample from a monkey,
but the human one
looks very similar.
You can see 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 layers of cells in each
lateral geniculate nucleus.
The first two look a little
bit different.
If you look carefully, they're
comprised of larger cells.
The other four are comprised
of smaller cells.
So people describe the cell
layer, made up of larger
cells, as magnocellular--
big cells.
And the other four layers as
parvocellular, or small cells.
The mangocellular layers tend
to have large cells.
A lot of their information comes
from the rods, the black
and white elements, good for
seeing in low vision.
They have large receptive
fields.
They cover relatively
large patches of the
world for each neuron.
Three times larger than the
parvocellular ones, the
neurons fire rapidly,
transiently, are color blind.
They're good in low contrast,
low lighting.
The parvocellular ones
are smaller.
They get a lot of their
input from the cones.
They have smaller receptive
fields.
They have slow, sustained
responses.
They don't turn on and
off very quickly.
They're wavelength sensitive.
So they can respond to color.
They operate best when things
are very bright.
They're unique to primates,
and there are 10
times more of them.
But again, even before you get
to the cortex, there's this
huge organization between
two modes or pathways of
perception, so you
can construct the
world as you see it.
And then we've gone over
before that as you
leave the nuclei --
the lateral geniculate nuclei--
then the next fiber
pathway takes you into the
primary visual cortex in the
back of your brain.
Now, vision is so important for
primates and people, that
when people estimate how much of
the neocortex is devoted to
different modalities, a common
estimate is that about half of
the brain is primarily
devoted to vision--
11% to touch, 3% to audition.
These are ballpark estimates.
But it shows you how visual we
are with our fellow primates.
There's many specialized
areas within the
human visual cortex.
They estimated some years ago it
was 32 distinct areas, each
performing a different tasks,
lots of specialization.
And another fascinating aspect
of vision is proliferation as
we go up into higher stations
of visual processing.
So in one lateral geniculate
nucleus in your brain-- and
you have two of them, one on
the left and one on the
right-- you have about
a million neurons.
They will send information that
will be interpreted by
about 250 million neurons
in your visual cortex.
Those will communicate about
400 million neurons in the
next level of processing.
And finally, there'll be
something like 1.3 billion
visual cortical neurons
in the brain,
overall, in a gross estimate.
It's as if to discover what
you're seeing, you're having
larger and larger populations
of neurons unpacking the
mystery of what initially
came into the brain very
impoverished information, that's
expanded to begin to
understand what you need to
perceive a face or a word or a
physical movement.
So a single lateral geniculate
neuron, it could be estimated,
will take 600 cortical neurons
to interpret what this lateral
geniculate neuron has
been exposed to.
Here's this area in the visual
cortex, where the information
arrives first into your brain
and primary visual cortex.
And when we think about cortex
in perception, in several
modalities, one of the striking
things is how it's
organized to achieve
certain goals.
So here, we're going to switch
for a moment to the parts of
your brain that move
your body--
motor cortex or that have
your sense of touch.
And when people stimulate these
and look at what they're
related to.
For example, in patients
undergoing treatment for
epilepsy or an animal study--
support this where you can do
much more expensive
experimentation--
a very striking thing occurs,
which is the number of neurons
devoted to different parts of
your body are radically
different than your
actual body size.
So this funny looking,
so-called homunculus
represents how many neurons,
for example, in your motor
cortex are devoted to different
parts of your body.
So it turns out that we do
incredible things with our
hands, so we devote, it seems
like, a tremendous amount of
this area to the hand.
That's what that
looks so large.
There's a reason we do
handshaking and handwriting
and typing with our hands
and not with our hips.
Because although our hips are
physically larger than our
hand, we devote an incredibly
small number of
neurons to do that.
So it's a trick of the brain,
given a certain limited size,
to blow up its representation
of what needs to be done
brilliantly.
And to reduce its representation
of parts of the
body that it doesn't have
to do too much with.
So what's blown up?
Your hand?
Things to do with your face,
so that you can speak?
Your tongue, because that has to
accomplish a lot, in terms
of speech, in terms of eating.
And things like your toes
and ankle are gypped of
representation, because you
don't do that much that's
brilliance.
There's a very clever strategy,
by the brain, to
devote the amount of neural
resources to make that part of
your body accomplish either
very complicated things or
very simple things.
And if people on the outside
looked like this--
this is what they
would look like.
Giant hands, giant head, and
a very shriveled up trunk.
So that's not what we look like,
but that's the way our
brain represents us, our bodies,
so that we could have
fantastically complicated
control of our hands and
things having to do with speech
around our mouth.
It's different for different
modalities.
For hearing, things
are organized
by frequency, tonotopy.
For vision, things are organized
in two ways.
Spatial relations
are maintained.
They have to be, so you know,
as different neurons saw
different receptive fields,
how's that all kept up?
Here's a kind of a rough
experiment, where a monkey
saw-- before it was, as they
politely say, sacrificed--
a display like this.
This is the brain of the
monkey, flattened out.
And you can see it has this
representation, like this.
Now you could say, well,
that's how we see.
We line everything up.
But this is not the part of our
brain that we associate
with conscious perception
at all.
But if you didn't keep the
spatial information aligned
correctly, you could never
interpret things, in the end,
correctly that go together, like
different parts of a hand
or different letters
within a word.
In humans, it's also in
the back of the brain.
It also keeps spatial
information.
But what do humans do,
and other primates?
They greatly expand the central
part of vision.
So here's the central part of
vision, the so-called fovea,
which is a small part of
the visual display.
Here is everything else that's
in peripheral vision.
So this is dark green,
dark purple.
But when it comes to the
representation in the visual
cortex, this small area
of what we see
becomes pretty large.
It's way overrepresented.
So just as the motor cortex over
represents the hand, the
visual cortex over represents
the cone
foveal part of the brain.
So they can do much more
examination, much more
computation on that small
foveated area.
So that's why it matters,
tremendously, where people put
their eyes.
Where they put their eyes is
where neuromachinery is
dedicated to do its most
brilliant analysis.
And peripheral regions, which
are large, in vision, get
relatively small
representation.
All we do, in the periphery,
is notice if something is
whizzing at our head.
And for that, we don't need
to be that sophisticated.
Now, what do neurons
communicate in
primary visual cortex?
Well, this is the, sort of,
seminal Nobel Prize-winning
work from Hubel and Wiesel, at
Harvard, who discovered that
what neurons respond to in
primary visual cortex is the
orientation of a piece of
something like this.
So here's a neuron that loves
a little bit of a stimulus.
You notice that disorientation?
Here's each of these lines
as of the neuron firing.
It generalizes if a bar is close
in orientation, it will
still like it, somewhat.
And if the bar moves away from
its preferred orientation, it
won't respond and all.
So these neurons are coding
something about local
orientation of little lines.
Those little lines will be
assembled later on in the
brain to represent a letter,
a word, a book, a face, a
chair, and so on.
But these neurons simply know
they're seeing a line of this
angle or that angle that will
be assembled later on for an
entire conscious percept.
And then that information will
go from primary visual cortex,
in two pathways, that have two
quite different properties,
but turn out to be the
super-information processing
pathways of your brain
and my brain.
So where do we first learn
about this fundamental
organization of how we see into
two giant highways of
information processing?
Well, the first studies where we
should study's in monkeys.
And I'll show you work
in humans as well.
And the major discovery was
this, that in our brains,
there's a so-called where
pathway that goes up in the
brain into the parietal cortex
and a what pathway that goes
into temporal lobe
or lower cortex.
And if you make lesions in these
different regions, one
form of vision is spared
and one is impaired
in selective ways.
So how did they discover this?
So again, here's the
big picture.
Early visual processing
information a what pathway to
know what objects are a
face, a word, a chair.
Or where things are, that
you might run to,
grab, or jump over.
So here was the experiment.
It was pretty simple.
Here were two food wells.
And monkeys that were eager to
get food would get rewarded,
if they would pick the
correct food well.
They didn't see where the food
was that was hidden, but they
would get to pick one
or the other.
And in one task they would have
to pick which food well
is closer to the stimulus.
That's a where task.
Where is this located?
That's the piece of information
that will tell me
where to get my food.
And you can see, here's the
performance of the animals,
their errors.
So it's good to be low.
They are eager to
get their food.
But if the animal had a
surgical lesion in the
parietal cortex, the where
pathway, they were very poor
at performing this task.
As if they couldn't appreciate
the spatial relation between
where the cylinder was located
and the food well.
On the other hand, monkeys who
had lesions made in the
temporal cortex were poor when
they had to make this task.
They would see two different
objects.
And they were taught that
one always meant that's
where the food is.
Let's pretend it's
the cylinder.
So in order to know the correct
answer, they would
have to say, OK, is it next to
this object or this object?
That's a what discrimination.
Is it a cylinder or a cube?
And now, the temporal lobe
lesions were the ones that
affected performance.
So it's as if one part of the
brain tells you where things
are, in vision--
parietal lobe.
And one tells you
what they are--
the temporal lobe.
So that's lesion studies
in monkeys.
But there's very interesting
things about when we look at
what cells communicate in these
two pathways that makes
sense in what we understand to
be the goals of these systems.
So for example, in the where
pathway, in the parietal
cortex, many neurons pick up
information from the fovea,
the central part of vision.
But the majority are sensitive
to stimuli in the periphery.
So if you imagine, a good
thing to know if you're
running, is in the periphery.
Are there things coming at your
head, things to avoid?
You might grab something here,
if you need to grab it there.
You would want to have a lot of
peripheral information for
spatial things around you.
And in fact, if a monkey was
looking at this spot, which is
away, entirely, from the
stimulus, it would respond to
both a large and small stimulus
in the periphery
quite strongly.
So these neurons are responding
to a pretty broad
range of space where things
could happen.
Neurons in the what pathway
have almost their entire
responsiveness in the fovea.
Because you know what something
is, if you're
reading a word and
looking at it.
If you're looking at a face,
they're figuring out
who the person is.
So it's only responding, these
kinds of neurons, to
information in the center.
But it has some very interesting
properties, even
at the level of singular
neurons.
So here's a depiction of an
experiment, now, from a monkey.
You're looking at a
single neuron or
small group of neurons.
And you present something
like a hand.
And you can see that those
neurons really like the hand.
Now, don't forget, for a primary
visual cortex, it just
sees lines.
It doesn't think about
the entire objects.
But by the time you get to the
higher levels of vision, it's
encoding an entire object.
And then, you can do experiments
that basically
interrogate, what does this
neuron discover in the world?
What is it interested in?
So if you turn the hand over,
it's still very interested.
You show it a less
detailed hand.
It's still very interested.
Maybe a bit less, but it's
still very interested.
A hand, this way, where all
the spatial relations have
changed still recognizes
a hand.
It still recognizes a hand with
a bit less enthusiasm.
But now, a mitten, which kind
of looks like a hand.
That barely counts
as a hand at all.
That neuron has lost interest
in coding that as a hand.
And you're showed other
things that have some
similarity in shape.
Because these all have
four elements in
them, like four fingers.
This neuron's not responding
at all.
It's not that it has four
things or lines.
It's a hand.
And then, you could even
worry about things.
Well, maybe this, because
it's from a person.
But if they see the face, this
neuron doesn't care.
So it's nothing about
the gross shape
or that it's a person.
This neuron is specialized,
foveally, for spotting a hand.
And not only that, these kinds
of neurons already have the
properties we described that are
big problems for vision.
So here's a neuron that's
responding to an upright face.
And then it's responding if the
face is turned on its side
pretty well.
The face is turned upside down,
a little less well, but
it's still responding
to a face.
If the face is distant,
it's still responding.
If the face changes expression,
it's still
responding.
And if we put a green filter on
it, so you have a Martian
person, it's still responding.
So all kinds of ways that a
face changes in the world,
this neuron is still firing.
And interestingly, this neuron
was firing for one of the
experimenters.
But it wasn't too interested
in the other experimenter.
So it's a neuron that's
generalizing all the different
views that you might
have of a person.
But it's responding to one
neuron versus another.
And there's been a lot
of fun in monkey
neurophysiology stuff.
There's a so-called Jennifer
Aniston cell, where
researchers have discovered
neurons, in monkeys, that seem
to respond to Jennifer Aniston,
for whatever reason.
And other specific
famous people.
Although, not particularly
meaningful to the primates.
And of course, in human brain
imaging, you can do tasks that
emphasize what an object
is or where it is.
And corresponding to the monkey
work, we see activation
in this where pathway towards
the parietal cortex.
If you have to make a
spatial judgment,
where things are located.
Or this lower temporal
lobe, what pathway.
You have to make a judgment
about what object you're
looking at.
So that lines up in intact
humans very much, with what we
see in primates with
invasive studies.
So we're going to end today
by discussing two kinds of
lesions in humans and some
spectacular impairments in the
what or where pathways.
So let me get you ready for
these films for a moment.
So one film you're going to see
is the patient who has a
great injury to the parts of
the brain in the parietal
cortex that serve our
where system.
So this is so-called Balint's
syndrome, in the Neurology.
These are bilateral injuries.
That means on both sides
of the brain, in
the parietal region.
They're pretty good at knowing
what something is, because the
temporal lobe pathway, the
what pathway, is intact.
But they have problems in
knowing where things are,
reaching for things, where to
put their gaze, estimating
distances, and navigation,
in general.
So I'll show you an example
of a patient like this.
And then the converse, a patient
who has big problems
in the what system.
And we'll start with that.
And I'll tell you just one last
bit of information to
think about.
That the what and where
distinction, sometimes, is not
as complete in every way
as you might imagine.
And so, sometimes people have
said, really, the where system
is better described as not
where things are, but the
information you need for
physical action in the world,
which is very close to where.
But it's a little
bit different.
And let me give you the kind
of what type of information
that the where system still
seems to have in it.
So here's a patient with
extensive damage in the what
system, in the lower parts
of the brain and
posteriorly for vision.
Terrible perception of shapes
and orientation of shapes.
Very bad what ability.
And she was asked, then, to
reach with an envelope to a
slot at different
orientations.
And what's striking is even
though if her hand was a
distance away-- so if she would
have to think, what is
the angle I would need
to approach it with--
she was terrible.
When she actually moved her hand
towards the slot, she was
surprisingly good.
So let me show you
the feeling.
So if this patient would have
to put her hand so that this
letter would fit into
this slot--
she was very poor at spatial
relations and knowing what
things were--
she couldn't line
them up at all.
But now, they said, well, please
put your hand out and
just stick it in.
And as her hand approaches it,
she changes orientations and
is correct.
Because in order to do things,
like to grab something--
think about it.
When you grab something, like a
pencil or a cup, you need a
little bit of knowledge
to know what it is.
You wouldn't grab things
similarly, whether they could
spill easily or be pointy
or painful.
A little bit what information
helps you guide even something
like a simple reaching, which
is a special task.
So it's not so much, maybe,
that the where
system is only where.
But it has just enough
information to guide actions
in the world, which has a tiny
bit of information about what
things are that you're
jumping over.
If you're going to run into
something, is it likely to be
soft or hard.